many of the things he said about bitcoin
also hold for other cryptocurrency
technologies that followed
after is can you say
something to why you think bitcoin
is the superior technology
from a pragmatic truth perspective than
say
ethereum but also other
crypto like bitcoin cash like other hard
forks of bitcoin
and uh or maybe things that might
yet to be invented tools yet to be
invented yeah
so this is a good point of argument
because a lot of people
have countered me and said bitcoin
cannot be absolute
absolute scarcity because you can fork
it and create something with
the same properties as bitcoin or
potentially even better
properties right you create something
with a deflationary monetary policy
that's what bitcoin cash was actually it
forked bitcoin with
all of the same properties except for
the block size that we alluded to
earlier
the problem is is that money is valued
again it's the good with a configuration
of demand
that is predominantly marketability
so it is valued based on its liquidity
that is how many other trading partners
are there
in that monetary network so it is a
network valued because of its liquidity
and network effects
so any new entrant into the market for
money
will always incentivize to always choose
the money with the deepest liquidity and
the most network effects
this is why money has tended to be a
winner take all market
because it's essentially a single
purpose tool right it is a tool
for if we consider that tools are time
saving devices
right the shovel lets you dig more holes
per man hour than you can with your bare
hands
money is a tool there's yet another
definition of money
that lets us calculate negotiate and
execute trades more quickly
so that function tends to
coalesce towards one solution
and so the short answer would be that
for the same
reasons quantifiable reasons right like
inflation resistance
and and liquidity and network effects
that we have one
analog gold we're only likely to have
one digital gold
and i think the bitcoin cash fork proves
that out empirically it's a good
a good case study because well four case
study right but
okay so that that's really well put so
like gold was sticky
uh yeah once it was accepted the network
effects the
winner take all yeah took over and
here's a
fundamentally different kind of like
analog versus digital is a leap
of technologies that's right and you're
suggesting that
there may not be
there's unlikely to be other leaps of
that kind
into a whole nother kind of space of
technologies
i would argue that bitcoin is kind of
like the ideological synthesis
of gold taking the monetary properties
of gold and combining them with the
internet itself
right and in doing so it has essentially
perfected the properties of money
right you can't get more divisible
durable recognizable portable or scarce
than bitcoin
so satoshi has kind of he left
no design space for a superior
technology
to intercede and out compete bitcoin at
this point now that it's established
liquidity and
far superior technology right yeah but
it's it's a combination of the tech
itself
and the social layer that
they're all connected and then the
political as well i mean but you know
the portability for example
that's the another way to phrase that is
the what is it
the scaling so the number of
transactions
that's the limitation for bitcoin that
many argue is a feature many argue is a
bug you have
you have a bunch of cryptocurrency
technologies that are able to achieve
much higher much faster frequency
of transactions much more transactions
you know
all that kind of stuff what are your
thoughts on that
uh you know the the low level of
transactions is possible with bitcoin
do you think that's a feature do you
think that's a bug necessary
for security actually and even these
other crypto assets that settle more
quickly they settle with less assurance
of finality so nick card has a great
piece on this actually called
it's the settlement insurance is stupid
it's really good where
the gist of it is that there is more
work
being done in each block of bitcoin that
it can't it is
less vulnerable to reversion so it's
it's giving you higher degrees of
assurance
that your settlement or your trade has
occurred with finality
whereas other blockchains are much more
vulnerable
and again with bitcoin the evolutionary
path of money
with gold is that it was first
used as a collectible it then became
used as a store value
after it had stored enough value it
became being it began to be used as a
medium of exchange
and then finally when it was used widely
enough as a medium of exchange it
becomes a unit of account
we actually start to think in the money
bitcoin's following a similar path
so started out as kind of a collectible
today i would argue it's a store value
one of the most effective store value
we've ever seen
so that evolutionary path that bitcoin's
following is similar to gold
first a collectible today is store value
to be an effective store value it has to
optimize
for supply cap yes that has to be the
first
and this is all bitcoin really needs to
do to be successful by the way
exactly what it's been doing for 12
years virtually flawlessly
which is keep creating a block every 10
minutes and keep enforcing a supply cap
of 21 million
as long as those two things hold it
is uh sound money the ultimate sound
money the
the most inflation resistant money
there's ever been
it's actually completely immune
it's taken unexpected inflation to zero
percent we know with perfect certainty
what bitcoin supply will ever be
for it to be used more broadly as a
medium of exchange
it can't make trade-offs at the base
layer to be
uh to increase its portability for
instance even though it's
portability is maybe kind of a misnomer
because bitcoin has extremely high
portability
just doesn't have extremely high
transaction throughput so we could say
you can move it pretty quickly anywhere
in the world as long as you're willing
to bid
up uh for the block space but you can't
satisfy all the world's economic volume
you can't do 300 million transactions
per second like you can on a centralized
database like visa
but bitcoin needs to be this
it has to be a store value first before
it can be a medium of exchange
so it has to protect the supply cap
first before making any trade-offs for
that
and i would argue that that's why
bitcoin is so rigid
is that it's optimized for survivability
and optimized for that supply cap and
it's
pushing experimentation and
other features that would increase his
transaction throughput to higher layers
so i think lightning network is
something that's very interesting
it's still early but there's a lot of
throughput already being used on the on
the lightning network
and it makes you know some slight
trade-offs in terms of the trust
minimization of bitcoin you end up
trusting these
these smart contracts instead to move
the bitcoin but you pick up nearly
unlimited transaction throughput
so that's how and that's how biology
evolves that's how the internet evolved
it evolves in layers
so i think bitcoin you can sort of
conceive of it as the latest layer to
the internet
and it's one that preserves this store
value property better than any asset
we've ever had
you